nos comunicamos con maría jesús vega
portavoz de acnur en españa que se
conecta con nosotros desde madrid
debería fra 24 y cuéntenos cómo veíamos
el nuevo espacio nuevo campamento tiene
justamente cada vida solo para 3.000
personas pero memoria vivían alrededor
de 13 mil qué va a pasar con los otros
10.000 refugiados en estas condiciones
así es las autoridades digas están
poniendo en marcha este campamento desde
acnur
hemos puesto a disposición de el
gobierno de grecia 2000 carpas tiendas
de campaña que podrían alojar a la
totalidad de estas personas que se han
quedado solicitantes de asilo refugiados
que se han quedado en situación de calle
y que llevan ya varios días algunos de
ellos durmiendo a la intemperie en
playas en bosques y muchos de ellos
están en situación muy vulnerable
enfermos embarazadas niños muy pequeños
entonces este trabajo que están
desarrollando en las autoridades griegas
con apoyo de expertos en logística de
acnur y con los materiales que les
estamos ofreciendo pues es lo que
tratamos ahora mismo de que pueda
agilizarse para que haya más personas
que puedan tener un techo bajo el que
cobijarse después de esta última
experiencia tan tremenda que han tenido
que vivir
bueno pero más allá de esta nueva crisis
desatada tras el incendio y justamente
en la crisis migratoria en europa pues
es un problema estructural que hacer
para garantizar los derechos humanos de
los migrantes que viven en condiciones
de vulnerabilidad en campamentos como
éste el de moria que son los más grandes
del mundo
estamos hablando de una situación
endémica desde ayuna hemos llamado la
atención desde hace muchísimos meses
sobre las terribles condiciones en las
que se encuentran a nivel global 27 mil
personas en este momento en las islas
del mar egeo en 5 centros gestionados
por el gobierno de grecia que tienen
capacidad para simplemente 5500 personas
entonces estas condiciones de
hacinamiento tremendas no solamente
están poniendo en riesgo de producción a
muchos de ellos de violaciones de
violencia sexual de abusos de robos de
conflictos sino que además con la
situación de kobe y de confinamiento no
hay posibilidad de poder guardar una
distancia social de poder hacer un
lavado de manos etcétera entonces esta
situación en la que estamos ahora
tratando de apoyar a las autoridades y
poniendo como digo a disposición todos
estos materiales desde tiendas bidones
letrina
tanques de agua que tanta falta hacen
tiene que ser una cosa absolutamente
provisional porque hacen falta
soluciones a largo plazo como venimos
reclamando desde hace muchísimo tiempo
necesitamos que se descongestionen las
islas griegas que la gente pueda tener
una dignidad en su forma de vida que
todos estos refugiados que vienen de
siria de irak de afganistán te de congo
de somalia después de haber vivido el
horror de guerras de persecución puedan
tener cierta habilidad cuando llegan a
europa
pues justamente es en la siguiente
pregunta porque el tema de la migración
no sólo le corresponde europa sino
también a los países de origen de los
migrantes qué responsabilidad tiene
europa en la crisis que se vive en estos
países por ejemplo que usted menciona de
medio oriente o de áfrica y entonces qué
hacer al respecto para darle una
solución estructural a este tema
bueno en primer lugar europa en este
momento lo que lo que debe hacer y ha
habido algunos pasos positivos es apoyar
a grecia tanto a nivel económico para
poder tener recursos para afrontar esta
situación de estas personas como a la
hora de reubicar y realojar a todos
estos refugiados que están entrando por
grecia porque es uno de los países
frontera del mediterráneo' como lo es
italia como lo es españa entonces hay
que hacer un reparto de
responsabilidades de todos los países de
la unión europea esto por un lado para
que no continúe esta situación en europa
y por otro lado lo que es fundamental es
seguir reforzando la inversión en
procesos de paz en identificación de
situaciones de riesgo en países antes de
que los conflictos estallen y también
invertir en resolución de conflictos y
en contribuciones internacionales en
cooperación internacional
si la gente pudiera tener
legislación y así los procedimientos de
asilo y una situación digna en los
países por los que transitan
probablemente no se marcharían nadie
sale por gusto y menos dejando su casa y
su país cuando hay un conflicto te vas
para salvar tu vida de tus hijos así que
en esa él se pone el foco